I love a little spoon why cuz I don't
know it just feels fancier it makes me
feel like a giant we just had three
cheesecakes in one day it's amazingly
fluffy and rich how's that possible the
fun isn't stuff you have never stopped
we are going to go on three different
secret menu item adventures at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
edit Spri we're doing secret menu items
I don't that we'd heard about from word
of mouth gonna feel like a secret agent
mmm yeah international man of mystery
Steven Lim I would want to be James
Bond's nemesis I want my own volcano
personal if we're going to it's a little
shop named Shake Shack I've been there
yeah me too but I have never had their
secret menu item peanut butter bacon
burger this one goes to you maybe
sometimes secret sound too crazy or too
good or too weird to be true mm-hmm
that's what makes the drink let's go Oh
nailed it hey guys I'm mark Rosati the
culinary director Shake Shack and we're
here right now in New York City talking
about a very cool burger that's kind of
a fan favorite secret item it's a peanut
butter bacon burger I'm not sure I've
heard of that combination before in
Missouri there was a place called the
wheel in and they opened up with an
iconic burger called the goober burger
it was a hamburger with peanut butter
sauce and lettuce and tomato what I
wanted to do was do a version that kind
of had some other flavor components he
did it for one day on a weekend on
Saturday he sold 30 that next Saturday
we sold 300 and ever since then it's
never gone back on the menu but you can
ask for a plain burger with bacon and
that is ground fresh daily its sear on
our grill with salt and pepper so gets a
nice crust on the juices are locked
inside I will give you a side of peanut
butter sauce so you can marry those two
worlds together yourself at the table
we've had some guests I'll actually add
pickles to it too which I think works
I'm definitely going pickles this is it
this is exciting we knew about this
secret menu item we didn't know about
this secret menu item which is a Shandy
it's our house lemonade and their beer
that
Brewing Company beers they brew it for
them they bear it for them already drunk
very refreshing Shan tacular peanut
sauce is my jam literally and
figuratively so in a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich it's just a peanut butter
and peanut butter
exactly that's a consistency I want
right there nice and goopy gooey oh I
gotta use that too okay I got peanut
sauce
woah in like a river streaming like a
Netflix you need to enunciate peanut
sauce a little bit better for me I'm
gonna go for it okay let's do it don't
[Music]
mmm everything I need to wash this down
with something I think we should have
got glasses of milk actually
little-known fact about me my family's
Chinese but they're actually from
Malaysia a very classic dishes like
satay with peanut sauce that's just that
beef peanut sauce plus in an American
burger like this is me in a dish I'm
gonna try this with a pickle cheese
again mmm oh that is the winner I'm not
saying I've ever been pregnant but if
you're pregnant right now they're having
some weird cravings I highly recommend
peanut butter and pickles yeah you get
the little bit of vinegar to cut through
the thickness of the peanut butter it's
crisp and light my really enjoying this
right now I am really going to play now
his matches your sweater
all right we just had that Shake Shack
burger actually wasn't as crazy I
thought it would be I was hoping it
would be good and it was good secret
menu best that goes here knew the secret
so you should whisper it man you bad
Starbucks employees playing that there's
no such thing as a secret menu people
just like how to make that stuff up and
just assign names to it however they are
willing to do pretty much anything for
you want to drink is I'm really a secret
menu it's just letting people do
whatever they want which is which is
where she committees come from how
society crumbles we're actually going to
have another burger now at a place
called Gramercy Tavern I Love New York
look at this city look at this you love
it now cuz that video Chuy hasn't
crushed your soul yet
[Music]
my name is Rafiq Celine we're at
Gramercy Tavern I'm gonna cook a burger
for you today we have a off-menu
bacon burger make 40 a day 20 for lunch
20 for dinner we run out we're out so
why does the burger exist one it's
really really delicious too we decided
to bring in half cows so that we can
utilize all the parts of the cow which
kind of forced us to be creative yes we
have the ribeye the filet all the other
trim we grind into our burger special we
are 100% not going out and buying around
beef that's what differentiates our
burger from other burgers so we have a
full butchery team downstairs
Andrew grinds the meat we grind fresh
every single day then he forms the
patties the bacon for the burger it's
cured with a sugar salt solution and
then it gets smoked the burger gets
grilled to order on a wood fire grill it
is quite special the flavor that that
grill imparts on the burger they make
the buns fresh every single morning the
bun gets lightly toasted not only the
bacon like smoked and delicious and
house-made we also grill it to order we
melt the cheese these little cast-iron
skillets and kind of pour it sauce the
burger in a way with the cheese we do
serve it with butter lettuce red onion
and pickled Fresno chilies and then top
it with the bacon put it on the bun
that's it that we serve it first we had
a Shake Shack burger that was so popular
the day it was released that they made
it into a secret menu item now I've got
into the practical secret menu item
because of the other things that they
don't want to waste but turn into this
beautiful thing we try this cider
[Music]
I feel like you're a cider guy yeah it's
what I drink growing up five year old
Stephen here just adds an alcohol and
we're good to go got a sad that we're
not sharing a burger but I'm not oh my
god this is bun first time I tried to
pick up that like a marshmallow
isn't it like what McDonald's burgers
look like in the commercial but never in
real life you're like making the sign of
the Cross there you know when a food is
so good that your legs start shaking
mm-hmm my leg is like quivering right
now the taste of the patty is prominent
there is like a deeper flavor of meat
happening here this food has a soul
smoky soul the flavor of the would just
like not only imparted this open the
food it's like living in the food the
burger falls in place as part of a
process and to put it on the menu would
ruin it and that's what I love that it's
a practical secret menu burger I mean
I'm excited about this burger okay
that's when we got to leave because when
the bad puns come we gotta Gaddy all
puns are great come on over um
Nover Adam Bianchi you want to keep that
cookie me a little bag of cookies from
the tavern oh great burgers and great
pastries what
give me one work one word to describe
that burger ah that's it you get a sound
effect secret menu back secret back so
the reason why I people love to get many
items hasn't studied a lot one theory is
that people like the idea of feeling
exclusive for relatively inexpensive
price you need to pay to play with
secret menus you just got to know to
play I like being in on a secret I don't
hear secret about me I secretly watch
asian dramas I knew that about you like
when you really hate vlogging Steven I
can't think you're in control the camera
here take it going to a place that
specializes in caviar called Petrosian
say it's all time but this is going to
be the most money that we've ever spent
on the show and the most money we're
going to spend on season two secret
number three
my name is Richard Farnum I'm the
executive chef at [ __ ] personal
restaurant and today you are going to
try the caviar souffle
this dish is your creation is that
correct one person was real story with
Alex on the other honor we talked to
make expensive dish for breakfast and
instead we talked about making omelet to
make scrambled eggs as making Zuffa say
oh why not putting caviar on it so we
put caviar listen why not bring the most
expensive caviar to taste souffle which
does better and we say well that is very
good when we not smoked the dish so we
smoked the dish with upper we smoked it
take is approximately like a man smart
enough to get the old process but we on
top of it now it's off menu it's cause
I'm a Guinness Book just skip over say
we've heard about your superhero idea by
the surface it we just felt about your
souffle secrets characterized very long
yeah
Guinness record for what the most
expensive Sufi order we didn't know it's
going to be the most expensive we just
designed to taste good get the base of
the souffle with the H quail eggs we put
in a mode which in over we are going to
you have carrier inside this egg white
cloud I'm using the most expensive
caviar while etc it's nice much
beautiful gold color well that's going
to be the souffle and yellow decoration
on top of that edible gold leaf is going
to be smoked right away after that with
applewood smoked I'm using a 200 years
old Vantage cognac and we are going to
film it tableside
so how much is the superfine $2,500
perfect what to do
[Music]
and I recommend I love that what was
just pudding is just don't be picky just
go forward to it yeah what's the drink
real quick
champagne Cheers you okay there
no not okay it's so tiny I'm not waiting
for you go go please yeah
visually it's kind of like a mini
cheesecake with blackberry a jam yes
this year's
[Music]
that's quite amazing that's how carriers
beat Wow hole got the creamy egg at the
bottom you've got this buzz of that
cognac floating up there kind of beating
like some pastry vibes from it this
toast plate is quite nice anyway for me
my [ __ ] know
[Music]
it's smooth like butter but it still has
that ocean saltiness washing over you
caviar can be daunting for somebody to
eat this is a caviar that anybody can
enjoy you okay there
I just burped and relived it again and
and you know that was like the greatest
burp of my life isn't it crazy that this
thing is plated in gold and that's not
the star of the dish I mean you see it's
like oh my god well but you open it up
and it's there's the gold then you've
struck gold it's like cracking open a
fresh oyster but the shell is made of a
cloud like I don't want to finish it no
no no right oh wait do we need to save
some of this for Adam
no okay yes I'll save him a toast guys
there's a banana in my pocket interview
any who eating some kind of pricey crap
on this show this takes the cake though
it takes the souffle we just had three
different secret menu items /off menu
items which dish was the most worth it
to you
I'll go first so Shake Shack it's like
one of those things that should be on
the secret menu because somebody sees it
they're just like what are you doing Jay
check but then if you order you're like
oh I know what I was doing and you were
doing Shake Shack my worth that winner
barely barely barely I'm going with
Gramercy Tavern oh my god best burger
I've got in New York yes did I feel like
I was part of a secret organization that
runs the whole world eating that souffle
kinda probably the most unique single
bite I've ever had is it something I'm
going to be craving all the time I just
don't have a caviar tune I'm more of a
burger to Gramercy Tavern worth it
winner you're getting a $29 burger dish
is that expensive for a burger yeah it
is is it the best burger I've ever
tasted I think so Adam whoa worth ah ha
ha ha that is a triple what
the winner freeway no when was a New
York City been nice a small utensil is
just aesthetically more pleasing in
every way it makes me feel like the food
is lasting longer cuz I can only load so
much up on each spoon not sure I agree
with that
oh yes